hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to well
it's that time of the year again and for
some reason so many people get angry and
stressed out but why we have Halloween
Thanksgiving and Christmas three of the
best holidays of all time but why is it
people get this negative feeling this
bad churning in their stomach that they
can't avoid well I think I have the
answer and I'm going to tell you insult
it's the holiday clusterfuck holiday
clusterfuck citizens gather together to
run amok but flying everywhere folks
pulling out their hair people are waving
while paying with great despair if we
don't feel winter with dollar bills then
your depression Peaks on top
we'd rather have dressed them to be real
depressed so we all shop until we drop
malls crowded everyplace nowhere a
parking space everyone screaming get
your ass out of my face fighting kids
cheap costumes lines in all the
bathrooms paying a fortune extortions
now in full bloom people are shoving
while claiming they're loving that
holiday joy they feel and your kids feel
that joy if you buy the right toy so
better keep your eyes peeled holiday
clusterfuck holiday clusterfuck see the
sins gather together to run numb what
antiques and Christmas comes suicide
rates go my keys widen buy me a robotic
psychopath holidays jumble three months
is a bundle to handle with grace and
ease we must make a living so it's
Thanksgiving jump straight to Chris go
away going and gone change decorations
out on your front
losing that magical touch seeing your
in-laws three times is too good
trick-or-treat Merry Christmas
going to church for your annual mass
Kwanzaa Hanukkah - let's get it right
someone's liable to sue
holiday clusterfuck holiday clusterfuck
millions of billions find they're just
shit out of luck visiting Santa's trip
lying straight to your kids pray they
don't need therapy for your time evening
this shit comes earlier seems almost
every year making us spend away
Christmas if we vote it should not be
promoted right after Christmas and
Halloween Thanksgivings in between
putting on more weight than shampoo one
link wizzy snow falling everywhere
traffic so real nightmare can't wait for
summer a bummer work kind of scary
emotions flying our patience is dying
what happened to all our cheer we wish
mommy our way until Valentine's Day
thank God it's just one side all the day
TV specials watching Santa Claus and
Jesus wrestle sending out Christmas
cards to wishing good cheer to folks you
hardly know it's the holiday
the holiday
they clustered a cluster when did this
time of year for love cheer start Juicin
someone cut us a break help us for
heaven's sake we're crowding while
drowning please God no more fruitcakes
get lots of oil so put on your smile's
don't let them know how you feel we all
have to think it so salad up and take it
and chow on your Christmas
ha ha